or an audience settle down and we're
starting okay yes okay so welcome to
part two on reinforcement learning
hidden theory and new super fast
algorithms so is your Kol this was
basically long history I mean joint work
starting back in my first sabbatical
with this guy Vivek Borkar who's now at
iit bombay and my graduate student here
Aditya Devaraj and the last time you had
a crash course in stochastic
approximation and some applications just
briefly mentioning reinforcement
learning and empirical risk minimization
and we went through a lot of concepts
really quickly and the big thing was
this stochastic differential equation
and asymptotic covariance for mr. Kaster
approximation and that's what I would
call the hidden theory I mean again
anybody who worked in CSV approximation
would laugh at me for calling the hidden
theory but I've talked to enough people
in reinforcement learning to know that
it's almost unknown in the community
which is a real surprise
and I mean I'm sure some people would
would take issue with that but I mean I
just it's a very fractured community
okay so today it's a basically there'll
be a bit of a recap and and then I'm
going to explain what this is what this
is app algorithm is and I'll have to
walk through slowly there's some real
subtleties here and then we're gonna try
to apply this to reinforcement learning
and that's gonna require a crash course
in stochastic control so gonna have to
cover you know dynamic programming
equations in a few minutes and then
we'll go and put this to work so what's
really cool though is that at first
sight you'd think well that's obvious
but it'll never work and the thing is of
the fact that this theory to support
that this works is amazing and how well
it works blows my mind I still thought
it was a I thought you were kidding when
I first saw these experiments okay so um
so yeah so um I said what's the one
thing let's go back for a second what
they want to just mention again is that
when you do amount of Carl oh wait so
when you're just doing flat amount of
Carl you're trying to get them compute
the mean of a random variable we look at
this last time the best thing you could
do is this recursion and that grow
equals 1 that's the standard thing you
do averaging a bunch of random variables
that has optimized and public variance
and you put a G over here that's not one
you'll get higher variance okay but then
there's this ingenious trick of Rupert
and Pollock where you actually crank up
the game so by putting in a row there
which is less than 1 it's like blasting
up the game it's like putting a GN on
top that's blowing up if you do that
you'll get an infinite variance
algorithm on at all but then you average
the output of that and you get an
optimal variant algorithm and when you
compare the standard amount of Carla
scheme with this double scheme you see
the central limit theorem looks almost
the same so it's optimal ok so this this
is though these beautiful optimistic
results really it's very rarely see that
for stochastic parts
Meishan this is really special because
you lit have a very special problem just
estimating the mean of random variable
so although it's true into really
general conditions this trick is out has
optimized some total covariance I will
show you results where it really sucks I
mean just awful and so there's you know
so did you know by be where you know you
can't expect this all that fun okay
alright so um so let's let's do it so so
for yep we just think that that's the
miracle of this I mean it's unbelievable
that so you can so here it's all scalar
so but we could have done this in the
matrix case and you could either put in
a matrix gain which I'll review in a
second or you can forget the matrix gain
and just crank up a scale again and
average the result and in terms of
asymptotic covariance you don't learn
it's a thing which is amazing it's
absolutely amazing but on the other hand
sometimes asymptotics are really sharp
like they are here the CLT converges of
after thousand steps that looks perfect
and sometimes our sin talks don't tell
you much at all that happens sometimes
as well i mean an example is sometimes
large deviations theory is so a
worthless tool for designing hypothesis
testing rules because it'll LDP's just
take too long to kick in
but sometimes that's true some roses
doll and I'll show an example here work
where this asymptotic theory really
doesn't tell you very much okay so let's
do it
so here's a recap so and this is just
say so one way to get to optimize
covariance is through a matrix game so
we have this slightly modified Robinson
Munroe stochastic approximation scheme
they never had a matrix gain here they
had a scalar game and you interpret this
as an or that nosy noisy or ill
approximation to a know de assuming that
GN converges and we're here I'm always
going to take the gate here be 1 over N
and the G ends again is to optimize the
asymptotic covariance and improve
dynamics which we didn't really talk
about much lost time the basically
thinking about Newton Rapson throughout
those and that's the main thing we
really want to dig into in today's
lecture is what do we mean by this now
any computer scientists out there
you're hiding so if you're in this sort
of nips community there's only one way
you're allowed to analyze these
algorithms you have to have a finite and
bound so at time n I have to tell you
the probability of the air exceeding
some epsilon and and you know I'd love
that I would love to be able to do that
and and the thing is though forget it
all right forget it
it's just you're not gonna get it and
it's not going to be informative
all right now this I know it's awesome
topic and sometimes asymptotics don't
tell you anything but this is crisp
computable you know this you can use for
design this just makes you feel warm and
fuzzy but it shouldn't make you feel
warm and fuzzy because the bounds you
get will be so loose they won't be
informative so they won't help you with
design
they'll be so loose
and and and just you know for the record
by the way we had 1200 views on YouTube
a teacher told me is it this morning so
there'll be a big audience here if you
think you can do this for stochastic
approximation that I asked you to do
this look at the probability that one
over n s n is greater than epsilon where
SN is a sum
all right give me a pound so I've got a
finite state space Markov chain I've got
some function of that and I have a sum
and I want a bound like this that
doesn't exist all right so if you can't
just take standard Montecarlo and get a
fight and down that how can you expect
to do it for some fancy stochastic
proximation algorithm so so this
obsession with fine and balance has got
to stop
all right CS people you know I mean if
you can't crack that problem is open I
mean so there's one paper by Kent about
Peter Glenn at Stanford and it's there's
a bound like that but it's so loose it's
absurd it's worthless for anything any
kind of anything yeah oh that would be
called a great function in large
deviations so this function what you
ideally so if I take a log and then take
and then divide by n and take a limit
I'll get something like epsilon a
constant times epsilon squared basically
this is like Lin Yunnan and an expense
and a quadratic in F and epsilon
typically so so so yeah I mean so this
again if I take it if I take a log and
divide by n I'll get a computable limit
yeah for Markov chains fighting balance
it's an open problem
so um but this is a big fight I mean
people see this in the cs community they
say forget it I mean that's not in the
long run were all dead it's a sort of
all right but so this but this is a
beautiful because we can compute it
we know the optimal gain in this the
case of choosing matrix gain is to take
minus a inverse and in that case what
you end up doing is it looks like you're
just doing Montecarlo averaging that's
that's some intuition it's sort of
resembles in Newton Rapson and it's it's
super optimal again it's if you the the
optimal covariance is given by this
expression and it's less than equal to
anything else you get with any other
matrix game so that's and that the proof
of that is still like common soldier
type arguments it'll make an association
with just linear filtering all right so
so I think that this should not be
ignored that's the hidden theory but but
then this do you see any resemblance but
let's go push back on me this is
nonsense actually explain so let's go
back to this so this is really the OD e
when you do this matrix game business
that I've been was talking about we have
you know X dot equals a game times f bar
of X you know f bar of X was the
averaged out function but that a is
something at the limit
it's the derivative of f bar at the
place you're gonna eventually be that's
nothing like doing Rapson alright and so
that's not what we want and so that you
know that's that's what we have to think
about so how could we get something
closer to in reps and we're instead of
this being the derivative of F in theta
star have it the derivative of the theta
I'm at right now
that's gonna take some thinking and
that's that's one new idea from you know
so this work and here's the idea so we
want so again we want we want an
estimate of a at theta n which is a
derivative of f bar at theta and how do
you do that well here's how you do that
so you take your estimate here you know
just like you'd expect so that's the
game and you just do it exactly what
you'd think for these guys you sort of
have a stochastic approximation
incursion for these guys we're here this
a n is the current derivative right that
all looks natural right but there's a
gain here gamma and there and there's an
alpha in there and you all tell me what
am I going to do
I want to forget the past I don't want
this uniform average of all the all
these guys I've seen before I only want
to you know look at look recent
Thetas I want to forget quickly
dude I'm Steve yeah and the two times
come particular means that gamma ends
give you much bigger than alpha you know
basically that's that's how you forget
the past just crank up the game and you
put them way more weight on recent
observations in pacification and what
we're going to do is this we're going to
take again all fan equals one over and
that's where we have this very crisp
Theory for the stochastic for the
asymptotic covariance and experiments
that we've looked at we're taking this
to be one of the end of the row we're
always between a half and one and that's
that does it so then you get the right
over to even then if you actually go
through and and you know under Lipschitz
conditions and nice conditions you'll
get exactly the OD you want because
because this all just
that's that's that
so the SAP is right there that's what's
a prefer stick is a high-gain really
just to try to track the the track the
matrix now of course it's not
necessarily stable you know why should
this be stable when not C F F bar is not
the gradient of a convex function we're
not we're not solving a you know
optimization problem in reinforcement
learning which is I mean the main
motivation here and Newton reps and
there's no reason it should be doing
anything it's okay
so this has been the back of my mind all
my life that I've known what stochastic
approximations been up I mean
reinforcement learning has been about
but I never expect it to work and it
contacts the reinforcement learning
that's that's why it took a while to
even doing experiments so gel conditions
for convergence are open but we get
really lucky in the context of Q
learning it's amazing so that's why I
want to explain in the next half-hour
and to do that how many people here are
fluent in in dynamic programming
equations and okay all right so I said
last time that all the function
equations that she has to control this
forum I I've got some mapping F that
takes a function and a stochastic
process this is a real valued function
actually
and again this conditional expectation
is always zero all right and I said last
time that this fee n is gonna be stayed
in action I'll make that precise now I
didn't make it precise last time and
then I said that all of these these are
reinforcement learning algorithms not
all of them but many many of them is
like what's called a choleric and
relaxation so instead of searching over
all functions 8star you search over
parameter its family and instead of
asking this conditional expectation b0
you take a adapted d dimensional
stochastic process and you want the
expectation of this product to be zero
so if this holds then this holds for any
d dimensional adapted stochastic process
data now we're just looking at me to
speak to z1 so the design of these
algorithms you've got to divide design
the the parameterize function class
you've got to design the test functions
and so yeah and this is in TV and
coloring these are the what's called
eligibility vectors you always see that
what's amazing is that when TD Lenny was
introduced there was no motivation for
the algorithm and it wasn't until later
on you know control people got into it
that you know the interpretation is a
clerk and the relaxation was made so if
you look at the original papers on TV
learning there wasn't really much
motivation
Watkins came first gee learning came
first where the motivation was really
clear you weren't trying to approximate
at all you were try exactly compute a
value function the form of the equations
was copied in TD learning there was the
only motivation but again these
algorithms are special cases of
stochastic approximation and seeing that
to you reviewers at nips and professors
in New Jersey you know who you are
okay so let's let's be more specific now
so that was very very general let's be
more specific so let's take a finite
state space fine action space setting
just so that I I can make statements
that I know are true otherwise you need
special conditions I've got a state
process X and an input process you these
are also the actions and and I've got
this probability of going to a set a one
hop starting from a state X and input u
and then prior history it's like it's a
controlled Markov process because the
prior history doesn't matter so so this
conditional probability only depends on
the current input or action the current
state and the set a alright and if it's
a finite state space we'll take a to be
a point so it's a property of
transitioning
from the state extra state ex-prime they
will just be X Prime and we can have a
cost function which is a function on
States and actions and here we're going
to look at this kind of cost optimal
control average cost is could be treated
but it's a little trickier alright and
there's a value function alright so we
minimize this overall input sequences of
this infinite discounted cost and we
have this initial condition for each
initial condition we have this
minimization and it solves a Spillman
equation alright so eighth star of X is
the value function any star of X is just
the minimum of something like that I've
got the current cost plus the cost to go
that's what that is you see this a
deterministic optimal control it's
exactly the same thing the only thing
different is you've got a conditional
expectation
so if it's um is obviously there's a if
you look at this when N equals zero you
get the C of X u that's the first term
no you see that there and all this is is
the remaining N equals one to infinity
that's the derivation
you're happy and you see there's a
conditional expectation there and that
is consistent with a conditional
expectation there
all right all right so what did what did
Watkins do in the 80s there was
ingenious we have this bellman equation
which involves an expectation and we've
seen expectation you think I can use
Monte Carlo methods to approximate the
solution equation well the problem with
this fixed point equation is that
minimum outside the expectation you
basically you know for every you you
have to compute an expectation that's
like doing a whole bunch of simulations
in parallel for each you that's not good
not a very nice thing to do his his his
genius was to take the thing in brackets
and give that a name call it a cue
function I don't think I've explained
why he called it a key function and why
does he do that well I'll explain
well first of all each star is the
minimum over U of Q star right that's
what this is saying and that means we
can eliminate start from this equation
and get a fixpoint equation in queue you
see an 8 star there we'll forget that 8
stars a minimum of Q star so eliminate 8
star from this equation and you get
another bellman equation so you know so
this this I had a 8 star xn plus 1 now
I've got a Q lower bar of xn plus 1 so
it's the same thing okay so whenever you
still lower bar I'm just taking a
minimum over the second variable and
that's a fixed point equation and Q star
and now I've got an expectation of
something just something and I can I
could apply Monte Carlo methods so that
was why continues was it this this one
beautiful idea that made everything work
and it turns out this is if you notice
that about you know optimal control it
looks just like the Hamiltonian it's
it's really almost exactly that
especially when you look at this in
continuous time it's basically
Hamiltonian with the P of T plugged in
there's a paper in that I can share with
you if you'd like alright so that's what
you play with and now we can go through
and derive a drive q-learning
all right so I know but yeah further
things so yeah so it turns out that we
could have started the other way around
we could have defined Q star to be a
value function just as before where we
we fixed the initial X and we fixed the
initial you it turns out this this sum
is precisely the same as the
that's another way to think about
so this miss minimum minimizing over u1
u2 u3 I'm freezing initial you
okay so one thing one thing that's
really useful analysis I mean I'll
remind you about this again later is
that there's a one-to-one mapping
between Q functions and cost functions
so you give I mean again in the finite
state space action space I don't have to
worry about existence
give me a cost function this minimum
exists you know and and it's so it's a
solution to that 2dp equation
conversely give me a queue any Q you can
see that I can find the C just by taking
this and subtracting that so there's a
one-to-one mapping between cost
functions and Q functions that's not
true for value functions and and that
one-to-one mapping I'll call it this
squiggly Q star that's one that's a key
tool in analysis
hey I promised you all this would be fun
and I feel like you're not having fun I
don't know all right okay so again so
now let's put this in the language that
I used before I said that every dynamic
programming equation in stochastic
control is of this form of the
conditional expectation of something
equals zero all right and you can see
this is exactly like I had before this
is exactly some functional of Q star and
some random process in this case that
random process is the state at time n
plus 1 the previous state and the
previous action
now here's the cool thing that's easy I
always forget to say I can plug in any
stupid oblivious stochastic process you
and this equation will be satisfied it
doesn't have to be optimal they're
definitely anything just plug in some
stupid input now what can end up doing
is we're going to assume that U is noisy
enough it explores enough you'll see why
in a moment we're going to put in a some
stupid input they have it has to be
designed with some care which I'll
explain so the collec relaxation is
again just to a place q star with a
parameters family so I'm trying I've got
a film parameterize family say theta is
an RD and I have to design some D
dimensional stochastic process if theta
theta is an RD and I want to solve this
equation and and and here it's really
clear that I need to I mean I'll do
something with the input in order to
make this meaningful and the typical
thing you do is you have some sort of
you know the state feedback but then you
add some randomized randomization to it
in the finite in the original algorithm
of Watkins you had to make sure that the
well first of all X nu n turns out to be
a Markov chain when you have randomized
state feedback appear across as X nu n
and you had to make sure you chose the
randomized state feedback so you visit
every hair state action pair with
probability 1
to make sure that the the by very
process with Boyd's irreducible so for a
big state in a big action space that
could take you know a lot of time to
visit all this for those pairs
so the these organic intelligible attea
vectors and you how to design this
family and that should be done with some
intuition and this is still an open
field alright so this I can state this
as a goal and you can write down
stochastic proximity algorithm but is it
gonna converge in autism is pretty much
all open except in certain okay watkins
algorithm is this so again we're trying
to solve this this color can fix point
equation and and and in here it's
watkins design so first of all it's a
linearized parameter peremptories
permutation so I've got a big sigh you
know vector and you take theta n to be
exactly sorry value X nu and that's a
really common thing to do for your test
functions you just take take that basis
vector and use that here but here's the
here's the catch so I has an enormous
dimension because basically you
enumerate every state every state action
pair call X nu n the nth state action
pair and the nth entry of this vector is
just the indicator function of that pair
so really you're just this is this is
just a parameter zation of all functions
all possible functions so cute so
watkins algorithm is not an
approximation scheme you say it's a
simulation based method to compute
exactly a
she function
now in practice what you do is you
pretend your world as a Markovian with
state space size 12 and now and and you
just apply q-learning
you know even though the world is not
like that even though the world is some
very complex system you pretend it's not
and what's beautiful is the Chiellini is
is so black box you can dis apply it you
know even though the world doesn't fit
your assumptions or it'll work or not
you know who knows now what's really fun
you first of all again to my friends out
there there for cooler a name is a
special case a stochastic proximation
but the thing is you apply the theory
and you'll find out that the asymptotic
covariance is infinity if you just apply
it you know the standard and and it's in
basically if beta is bigger than 1/2 the
discount factor is bigger they have the
asymptotic covariance is infinity and
really infinity I mean really really the
rate of convergence isn't one of a
square root of n maybe it's 1 over N to
the point zero three it's so slow and
that's the big problem is it obvious
from this slide or it comes from the one
that you mentioned last in the last
lecture yeah it comes from it comes from
when you write down the the I remember
your covariance equation from the last
side yeah we need the eigenvalues of
this a matrix to be to have real part
less than minus 1/2 okay and the fact is
is that when you write down the a matrix
I think I have it
you'll find that that beta comes in and
if beta is bigger than 1/2 then you can
show the eigenvalues that hey matrix or
there's one eigenvalue that you can see
is
and a big advice to help I think I do
have in a moment I think okay the
question is can be zapped you learning
if we apply this this is newton-raphson
technique and I assume no you know I
mean this is an awful thing right I've
got this see this this is a function of
theta affair to say star this is that
this is a vector valued function if Zeta
n is positive as it is here because of
the men here there's a concave function
of theta is that useful I don't know
about Newton Rapson for concave
functions vector-valued concave
functions I did I did some googling I
didn't find anything you know I mean who
knows how this would work all right but
turns out it does so you can the answer
is yes we will zap q-learning and I'll
explain to you why it works
so first of all we need help so here is
a really boring problem
I mean catchin anything more boring
you've got a six state Markov chain and
the edges that refer to where you can
hop in in one step and all I want to do
is go to this place and go to bed
that's my goal I want to go over there
and lie down but you say you take off
the shelf stick a cooler name and you
run it and here's just a histogram of
one of the I don't know 20 some whatever
parameters you started at zero so you
know all the the pyramidal parameters it
was initialized at zero and you've got
this histogram they said this is like a
thousand independent simulations and
you've got this ball here and it does
converge and we proved it last lecture
we know q-learning
converges because you can show the OD is
stable but but it'll take a trillion
cent steps to get to where it's supposed
to go you know this is a this is after a
million samples it's below a hundred
where it's supposed to be at 486 it's
amazing it's a people whining about
chelating being slow for so long you
know they could have picked up any book
and stochastic approximation and seen
why so in this example you know the rate
of convergence is like again like 1 over
n because we haven't worked it out yet
but like it would be point zero two or
something at one of our end of the point
zero two instead of one of a square root
of n and and that's that's the reason
this problem so we need we need to do
something all right so let's go through
and and look what the a matrix is so
we'll be able to answer your question
and all that so the thing the f bar of
theta that we like to look at these of
this forum and it's this big ugly mess
here and if they and I remember it's the
derivative of this at a particular value
of theta now for a linear combination
that's really simple you know that's
going to be the basis vector now here
you've got a minimum at least we're
lucky there you know we've got sub
gradients all over the place and so we
can forget about derivatives but it's
look at sub gradients and it points a
differentiability in particular
here's it here's a theta okay
so you basically have you your your saw
of the basis vector there and you've got
it saw here but then a value to
particularly you it's a minimizer so
it's a policy associated with parameter
theta so this policy is the argument of
the Q function this is a policy you'd
use if you thought theta with the best
theta so when you're all done don't
forget you have to choose a control law
your control law will be that once once
you decide the Q function you think it's
now remember for Watkins algorithm Zeta
and is the same as that so you've got
this - you've got negative a positive
definite matrix that's nice and this
times this is just some sub matrix with
non-negative entries what ends up
happening is you can apply the parantha
B Gnaeus theory to analyze the top
eigenvalue of the inverse and and it
turns out that you know because this
outer product is similar to this head of
product you can get a bounds and 4-bit
beta bigger than 1/2 you find this
asymptotic covariance is infinity and
and that's true for this this there's
two different ways you can implement
off-the-shelf killer a name I mean one
is just the 1 over N and one is where
you keep a counter of how many times you
visited a particular state action pair
and so let's say a different gain for
each each theta value well the same is
true for that and here is like thing
that you mentioned to me and I asked you
we ordered the controller that you
specify here should be in such a way
that you need to visit each state action
pair infinitely oh yeah for Watkins
outcome that's right yeah and and and so
if you had a parameter it's family you'd
have to choose
you'd have to choose or use so that this
matrix is invertible you know and so
that was a little bit of exploration
possibly
that's right you know in order for this
matrix to be invertible you need to
visit every state action pair infinitely
often alright so there it is so you know
then then you just go through and
blindly apply this you know we've got
our RF is that thing that's in this red
color you just take that and plop it
down and then we have our our matrix
estimates well we've got all right all
right that's what I called a n before
the whole monster that's what's right
there and we go and plant it and apply
it
it's a n with this derivative which I'm
just writing down once more here it's
the best way the closest we can come to
new grab some and why should this work
there's no intuitive reason at some
point we're gonna have some beautiful
explanation you know but right now we
don't we just it's just calculus and I I
wish I had a intuitive reason like why
it works but I'll give you a proof right
now why it's stable is it cleared the
algorithm and all that
all right stable all right so here's
this remember I said that there's a
one-to-one mapping between cost
functions I mean I want to come at gel
cost function this is this is the only
symbol left was a squiggly symbol so
that's like a that little that's
actually called very Sigma in later so
that little little squiggle for any cost
function is a cue function and converse
if acute functioning I find a cost
function there's a one-to-one mapping
and so basically again given it given a
C that's like a C I can solve this
equation to get a q and conversely given
a Q this C is just that Q minus that
song there's a one-to-one mapping now
the reason that I'm emphasizing that is
it to analyze the cept you're learning
it turns out it's much better to look at
cost space for other than Q space make
it a change of variable and in fact it's
a one-to-one mapping it's cool all right
and here it is I said I give you a proof
I just realize I'm not giving you proof
I'm just telling you the conclusion it
turns out that if you if you take the
the given Q function estimate at time T
so you can go through and you you
construct this OTE
and then you look at it and what you can
show is that the Q of T goes along and
it's in some piecewise linear orbit and
at first thought I was really scared
there'd be some infinite limit cycle
like a piecewise linear infinite limit
cycle and then and then it turned out
that if you made a change of variable
and so forget QT let's look at the you
know for each T look at the
corresponding cost function associated
with okay turns out that solves this o2e
you're not saying I think so lucky I
hope all of you are that lucky someday
is to take some hack algorithm and then
play around with it and find out that
it's that trivial you know who would
have known you know it's just -
somebody's coining it's amazing so so
the OD is stable and and it and the Z's
is a - T's converge to C and therefore
you know QT converges to Q star of C
which is which is Q star
absolutely awesome and this is what this
is the ODF amount of Carlo you know if
you're just try doing doing boring
averaging the OD becomes this it's it
looks like this locally so if you start
out near the optimal Q function it has
the same OTE so you get Q dot equals
minus Q plus Q star but that's only
locally true if you start far away you
end up with this strange piecewise
linear behavior and that's because this
Q star function is kind of con concave
and under convex and piecewise linear
so this actually has a piecewise linear
trajectory
okay yeah and the proof I regret that
that I didn't include approve it
basically it's when you
nobody take too long yeah but it's again
we're exploiting the the the fact is the
minimum here it comes up and and when
one ugly term drops out when even when
you playing around
[Applause]
that's the magic that's the thing I
don't understand
so AF theta is the gradient the
derivative of f bar theta that also
turns out to have to have you have this
representation it's bizarre you know and
that's because of the minimum it just
comes out that way it's really strange
you look at this and you think we've got
the product rule you know so you'd have
two terms if you'd if you take the
derivative of this you think there'd be
two terms but one trim drops out and you
get this so because of this strange
formula for f bar of theta you get this
oh do you that's that's how it happens
that's just a bunch of algebra so again
next year I'll come back and say that
there's some Hamiltonian and it turns
out we're solving a variational problem
just like Michael Jordan tackled you
know next year there'll be some
beautiful theory I don't know something
in I don't know quantum computing
analysis right now it's just algebra
okay so let's just now go through it
there's some examples to illustrate what
happens so so again so again look at
this boring example and here's what
happens try anything you want and they
all fail take speedy q-learning it's
called take is a polynomial Q learning
this there's holy act Ruppert averaging
what this is it's like the worst of the
bunch and the best of the bunch and that
everything else is in between that's
basic what that is so this is a bellman
error so it's sort of a norm error in
that bellman equation and this is after
a million iterations the bellman error
is still you know it doesn't decrease
much after million steps well if you use
you use the servant Newton Rapson sort
of method adjust this computer
and so it shows that that you really do
need that sort of Newton Rapson part of
the algorithm you know the asymptotics
there's not enough so even though pali
equiped averaging will give you a Santa
like variance it's it's not doing that
well so again so it's true you've got to
be careful the central limit theorem is
amazing but sometimes it's not that
informative sometimes it is sometimes it
isn't computationally if there's an N
squared complexity yeah absolutely right
I agree I mean terms of in terms of
computational complexity we definitely
need to we know we know that there's an
ins we have an N squared complexity
there's no way is no way it's gonna make
up for that but yeah but still because
he because I don't know when this is
gonna come down yeah yeah so in this
case no way that matters you know but
when we get to higher dimensions if
we're looking at such a dumb problem
well let's come back to at the end the
fact the computational complexity issue
opens up all sorts of areas for research
okay so here's the thing so if you did
so so Roop would propose something that
he called stochastic raps them back in
the 80s and it was really just averaging
all the AMS nobody I mean it was a
little bit different but this averaging
all the Aeons and when you do that we
don't get this beautiful eau de we
haven't yet even be able to prove
stability I don't I don't know if it's
stable and it doesn't perform as well it
performs surprisingly well you know but
but not nearly as well as when you have
the few time scale algorithm now the
other thing you could do is say well
it's not fair to use a gain of G equals
one for Watkins because we know that
that's not a good idea but we know that
because we read the stochastic
proximation books okay so we can go
through and we can try to find the
scalar gain that optimizes Watkins and
see what happens and it kicks house if
you know compared to these other methods
so if you it turns they have to take G
equals 1500 to get the you know to get
optimal the optimal Verret variance and
that you know that's yeah that shows how
small those eigenvalues are so this is a
discount factor 0.99 which is not that's
big I mean really is it I mean it's a
it's a horizon of a hundred or something
that's that's not you
you see a lot of volatility but it's you
know it's it's awesome compared to these
other methods so the variance is huge
but alright so um and so the CLT is
really nice okay so this is after you
see after ten thousand steps so that
this is entry 18 and entry ten how do we
choose those entries this was the worst
entry where the CLT was the slowest to
converge and this was the best so you
know there were we did thousand
independent runs and you say wow the CLT
is not working well at all [ __ ] it's
perfect so red is theoretical CLT
identify K perfect predictor of what we
see my MATLAB might disagree and and
make these look different but that is
awesome how well after just ten thousand
steps and then if you go to a million
it's it's completely perfect you know so
the central limit theorem in this case
you know it's a really good predictor of
performance alright and in terms of if
you actually look at the local so again
if you look at the bellman error and you
look at sort of local conversion suppose
we're really kind of these other
algorithms and we initialize them very
close to where they're supposed to be a
theta star so remember that the
histogram I showed before we initialize
at zero and then and kuelen was just
slowly crawling to say to store suppose
we let its meet this said here's what
you want to be let's start you there
what can still sucks
even though even though we started the
exact right plays you know so with a
gain of 500 it's you know the bellman
error is way out here histogram is awful
after after a million a million samples
if you crank it up to 1500 bc it's much
better and and speedy in terms of the
bellman error it's actually the bellman
error is not so bad you see it's the
histograms
zero and 25 or so but but look here the
scale who is 164 these are competing
algorithms and here it's 50 so it's so
if we really were fair if we're fair to
ourselves and stretch that out then you
you could see how much dramatically
better it is to use the interrupts and
like algorithms the only reason we use a
scale is we wanted to keep the green guy
there you know a gain of 500 so Paul
yeah crew bird is like this uniform film
and air of this huge range and the
single time scale algorithm doesn't do
as well but does pretty well but when
you use a you know the to time scale
algorithm it's just very very you know
there's just another way of seeing this
different you can see the the slope is
right now we're getting the right slope
for these three different schemes
because I'm sure that the the single
time scale algorithm I'm sure I'm sure
once we prove stability we could prove
it has optimal also the covariance
that's trivial because once you get in a
region a certain region of the theta
star it's just like Monte Carlo you know
it's it's trivial that has the absolute
optimal variance but the the contents
are very different that's not and these
other guys just don't have a optimal
variance
all right here's a fun one so plainly
changing gears now let's look at
something complicated let's let's
optimize our options strategy first
trading stocks alright this is a based
on a well sequence of papers the first
one published with Johnson sickle is
been Ventura he was his student back in
the 80s he's now a professor at Stanford
and they were looking at a particular
optimal stopping time problem in finance
I'm not going to drive the formulas for
you you know it's but this it falls in
the same category as I showed you before
there's a functional fixpoint equation
involving a conditional expectation you
look at a choleric and relaxation and
you get a Q learning algorithm and you
can apply the theory is here so I'm not
going to show you the equation system
results so the state space is our 100
basically what they're taking is is the
observation of prices now one step back
two steps back up 200 steps back all
right 99 steps back just pertaining
that's a Markov process and the Q
function is ten to ten dimensional and
it's just gobbledygook they I there
wasn't a lot of motivation for the
function that was chosen this paper our
motivation is not to make a killing on
Wall Street it's just we want to compare
you know what happens when you use this
theory and apply it you know just into a
well study problem and this is something
with the civil papers so if you look at
the a matrix and you look at the real
part of the a matrix they're negative
but you've got a minus ten to the minus
five is the most negative and and and
and then here you have a stop that dad
but actually it's not as bad as I
thought it's a series the the worst
eigenvalue actually wait a second
is it - point one no I guess so actually
yeah I didn't I've said sounds bad as I
thought you the the worst eigenvalue is
less than minus 1/2 but it's but it's
it's not that far off it would be too
hard to fix this I'm sorry the first
time you had this mistake ever and
that's on camera
I flip this over around oh this we'd
have to pull this down sorry this is
practically zero ten the minus five
everybody and you know it's funny it's
this minus signs they can be confusing
we'd have to multiply by 10 to the 10 to
the 5 to make the roughly on the order
of 10 to the 5 to make this worst
eigenvalues be the lesson minus 1/2 as
we wish all right so yeah all of these
have been real part of lambda bigger
than minus 1/2 for everyone so they
didn't analyze the the asymptotic of
variance but they saw something was
wrong and in paint later papers they
introduced a matrix game and so I'm not
going to give this to you
but but basically they took the positive
definite part of a and they just used
that as the game and then they then and
then they also cranked up or the
negative definite part the minus
expectation of size I transpose and then
they multiply that by a large constant
and then the despite trial and error
they found the best constant so that was
their GM
so Gianna get the expectation of size I
transpose tons of scalar and the scalar
was chosen by trial and error until it
worked well so here's what happened so
with so we came back years later and
looked at you know use Monte Carlo to
estimate their their the a that comes
out use Monte Carlo to estimate the G
that comes up so this took you know you
know weeks and weeks just to get a
really accurate estimate and then here
the eigen values so they succeeded
here's the miracle not applying the
theory but just through trial and error
when they got the best constants they
got their worst eigen value be minus 0.5
to falling it's absolutely amazing so he
just made it so you have a finite
asymptotic ax covariance so it's just
purely by I mean the math was guided
them but they didn't know what it's
amazing all right so that's that and
then you compare it and we and they have
a finite asymptotic covariance we can
compute the theoretical variance and
here's what happens with zap q-learning
you've got the theoretical and and the
observed and you can see it's not quite
as predictive this is a really
numerically unstable problem I mean that
a matrix is barely invertible it's so
ill conditioned you know it's crazy you
know
so the fact that the CLT works at all is
amazing so this is after two million
samples and she won I guess with the
worst and entry seven was the best in
terms of CLT solidarity and here I don't
think it's too bad here that's that's a
bit so the theoretical versus observed
but with with this that CLT falls apart
and you can imagine they're so close to
have an infinite CLT that probably the
great of convergence is yield he is very
very slow when you that far from and
it's where in the assumption it's
remember their eigenvalues minus 0.5 0.5
to 5 if it was minus 0.5 the asymptotic
covariance would be infinity and so
there's probably a lot of numerical
addition to that you know see if he
doesn't work it all right and in terms
of what you get but you really care
about is the the average award a
histogram is valid and forget about this
I mean this is just you know doing time
all right let's go up to the end 10 to 2
million samples so zap q-learning gives
you the highest reward and always the
same basically it gives you one point
two three every time and and the
algorithm they proposed with G equals
200 was actually you know quite quite
good but has I guess you can't see it
all but it's quite yeah it has a much
bigger dispersion base it's way way way
less reliable what you're going to get I
[Music]
forgot which was their game was it 100
or 200 yeah so you crank up the gain a
bit more that's what I call good yeah I
should know that but with blue you can
see it's hiding there it's sort of
uniform almost so sometimes you'll get
it sometimes you'll get a pretty good
answer sometimes you won't get a good
answer at all I don't know if you can't
see it there's little bits of blue all
over the place here
and and this is a quite an easy thing so
in terms of complexity it's the same so
there's no no cost there they have a
matrix Kane algorithm so do we alright
so in terms of conclusions let's go back
to your point this is after this
beautiful walk to Point Reyes several
weeks better so the asymptotic
covariance is a beautiful design tool we
saw that sometimes it's also predictive
of performance like the case of Watkins
Q learning it's dead-on perfect for
predicting performance of the algorithm
in this case this finance example it's
not as good but it's pretty good and
this this particular example with
finance was numerically horrible I mean
the matrix has a condition number like
10 to the 4 so we don't we're not going
to do that in reality we're going to
create much better condition problems to
begin with so we'll choose a basis
functions that are more better
conditioned all of that the one example
is the fact it's 1,500 I don't know
anyway you'd get that 1500 except
through this technique of solving the
Lyapunov equation and and getting this
thing you know getting this value so but
but a big thing to remember is of these
two things going on here so I DT are not
saying asymptotic covariance a scintilla
covariance two things are working here
you know there's the asymptotic
covariance I believe in that it's really
useful but that Newton Rapson business
was important you know we saw that with
the comparison of poetic averaging
versus sabki learning so we didn't have
that Newton Rapson part and that's why
we weren't taming the dynamics in a way
and so the the bad dynamics of Q
learning were maintained and so when you
keep those two things in mind you know
it gives you a whole tool case for a
look at the design so so in terms of
future work conditions for a stable
algorithm under general function
approximation setting is an open part at
the moment now it turns out the OD
analysis goes through
you know it's amazing you still get
something like C dot equals minus C blah
blah blah it's it's not see anymore
something else but the OD analysis goes
through for any function approximation
so we just don't know if a is invertible
we don't have general conditions under
which a of theta so that's that's the
gap there for optimal stopping times
it's been resolved over the last month's
so that's that's solved I think there's
some technical issues but they're minor
and nothing that would bother anybody in
this field but then there's your point
what we'd like to do is is just keep
these things in mind and what's cool is
you know for the matrix game you can
just pick up a book what's your favorite
reduce complexity version of Newton
Rapson
and come up with a stochastic version of
it and then we can do things like to
improve the optimize the variance by say
a scalar game because we know how to do
that we can easily open up equations
find the optimal scale again forgive a
matrix game
and most likely I mean in high
dimensions certainly that's what's going
to happen and I should say that right
now the fashion is to say that matrix
gains are absurd Mike Jordan on Friday
said this could change at any moment at
a at Boyd fest last week so so so I'm
not saying it I mean it depends on the
problem I mean robotics they never have
high dimensional problems and it doesn't
make any sense not to use a matrix game
of course when you look at this
alphago that could it be doing a matrix
game with a million variables you know
who does this you know it depends but
that's that's gonna be fun I think it's
really gonna be fun to see one look at
compromises thank you yes well the thing
is that I can give you I can give
references on this so it you know a lot
of problems in control you have a lot of
insight into the structure of the value
function so in queueing models like we
were you looking at scheduling routing
and you've got delay costs we know the
value function looks quadratic it's like
a piecewise quadratic function plus some
junk and you just plug that in and I
have actually have a survey paper on on
taking naive models solve them or
approximately solve them and then you
take the solution of the naive problem
it did very very approximate model and
you plugged it in for a basis for the
original problem so that's that's one
technique I know I mean a lot of
problems we look at in control you have
convict city I mean you know we have
growth rate so it gives you all this
structure you can
that's that's one thing that you often
we have a lot of structure the problem
and in finance I mean there are so many
heuristics and you just plug them in and
that's an I'm looking forward to doing
we nope that's the heuristics on on
stopping rules for in finance I don't
think that they've properly used that in
then there's a question of designing the
Q function so the minimum is easy to
compute or control so when you're done
you have to have a policy and see you
directly doing that and also we want
this algorithm to be nice in the sense
of a of theta well that's out there but
we got right there nothing has to be
invertible so it's of course I mean you
have me and hopefully you can design it
so that's true as well but that's
something I don't know anything about
would make sense today I don't know how
to do that yeah I mean thinking that if
they were not negative definite then you
know if it's symmetric and all that then
we could add a little something and to
fix it but here is not symmetric and we
don't know it has negative we don't know
anything about it at this point so
values close to zero and then
well well trouble but the thing is that
as long as is a has what's got a stuck
right now is that for the general
function approximation setting this AF
datum ight have a zero eigen value and
then we don't know what to do and we
call e of I was in France headcount came
with a counter example with I mean with
you know where the eigen value was zero
with some special choosing so really is
an issue the general function
approximation not again not for optimal
stopping just for a completely generic
like what does that give my new zero in
that case I don't think it was intuition
yeah I didn't see any any intuition when
I read it it was just just just so much
you know it's just the fact that there's
a lack of compatibility that minimum is
a problem where's RAF theta
yeah the fact that there's a minimum
here makes this function and this vector
this vector very very different you know
and that difference isn't so important
for Watkins it's not so important for
optimal stopping but in general it is
figuring it out
oh yeah that was so that was it so in
Watkins algorithm you have to make sure
that the joint process Xu is an
irreducible Markov chain
meaning you visit each state action pair
infinitely often so that's where the
exploration comes in there I'm just
wondering whether there should be a
better randomization strategy that maybe
well I think that's what's so cool here
is here you're putting junk into the
system and what comes out as the optimal
policy now what some people like to do
one thing that there's a literature on
is to do it an oblivious randomized
policy with say probability one minus
one over N I mean whatever atom and with
the remaining probability you choose
your bet what you think is the best
policy things like that and you could
still prove convergence understanding
certain conditions for different
realizing policy does that affect it or
not oh yeah because it'll affect your
theta
that's right absolutely yeah that's
right so so and that's the thing is you
don't explore enough you're AF theta
could be very ill conditioned yep
absolutely so if you'd if you have a bad
imprinting a F theta horribly condition
absolutely
and that's why I kind of I mean we
should do an experiment but I have a
feeling that it was also they won't be
so pretty if we do that sort of
optimistic q-learning worth probability
you only explore with probably one of
our n I don't know if that's true I
don't I don't know why they would be I
don't I don't understand the motivation
I I don't know why you wouldn't just
learn first what the impatience is about
SD Jackson like infinitely often and
update that so we should be doing
Watkins but no matter what you can have
to be doing yes you'll have to be longer
I mean look it's the thing is if you
don't explore you know it'll take longer
to learn you can have your robot buzzing
around for years you know you could kiss
you'll explore much less if you if you
if you you know take what you think is
the optimal action with high probability
and nice explore probably one of around
so that that you know billion steps will
turn to a trillion I think I don't know
I don't I don't think it's a good
savings of time that's my good that's
what my gut tells me
okay thank you for your attention
[Applause]